Bundestags Vizepräsident Wolfgang Peggy
ruft diesen den nächsten top auf Teil
des ordnungspunkt 6 da geht es eben um
die Unterstützung der Protestbewegung im
Iran denn seit dem seit sieben Wochen
halten die Proteste an nachdem eine
22-jährige
getötet wurde davon geht man auf Gina
Massa Amini wurde ursprünglich
festgenommen weil sie ihr Kopftuch nicht
richtig getragen haben soll so wie es
die Sittenpolizei gern hätte und wurde
festgenommen und ist dann
zusammengebrochen und starb drei Tage
später seitdem protestieren die Menschen
trotz möglicher
Strafen bis hin zur Todesstrafe
herr Präsident liebe Kolleginnen und
Kollegen Liebe zuschauende im Iran gibt
es keine freien Wahlen es gibt keine
Selbstbestimmung es gibt keine
Gleichheit vor dem Gesetz es gibt keine
Freiheit der Meinung immer wieder haben
Iranerinnen und Iraner auf Reformen
vertraut sie haben darauf vertraut dass
die Republik sich von innen heraus
verändern kann immer wieder sind sie
enttäuscht worden immer wieder ist ihre
Hoffnung auf Freiheit und
Selbstbestimmung niedergeschlagen worden
immer wieder haben die Menschen im
iranien Glauben verloren denn die
Islamische Republik ist keine Demokratie
am 20 September wurde Gina Master armini
eine iranische Kurdin in Gewahrsam von
Sicherheitsbehörden getötet ihr Tod war
kein tragischer Unfall sondern Mord
seitdem gehen jeden Tag Tausende und
Abertausende auf die Straße nicht etwa
weil sie einen Iran ohne Hijab wollen
sondern weil sie ein Iran wollen indem
man nicht zu jeder Zeit an jedem Ort
ohne einen einzigen gerechtfertigten
Grund von
sittenpolizeirevolutionsgarten oder
einfach nur staatlich bezahlten
Schlägertrupps verhaftet entführt
gefoltert oder getötet werden kann sie
wollen einen Iran ohne dieses Regime
meine Damen und Herren
sie rufen Tod dem Diktator der Mut und
die Tapferkeit dieser Menschen ist
grenzenlos denn anders als bei uns
arbeiten die Sicherheitsbehörden nicht
zu Ihrer Sicherheit sondern zur
Sicherung des Machtapparats mehrere
hundert Menschen wurden seit Beginn der
Proteste getötet das scheinparlament in
dem echte Reformer gar nicht zur Wahl
zugelassen sind hat mit einer 80 Prozent
Mehrheit entschieden dass 15.000
politische Gefangene hingerichtet werden
sollen die Mullahs fürchten den Ruf nach
Freiheit uns ist die Freiheitsbewegung
ein leuchtendes Beispiel
die Mehrheit dieses Parlaments
unterstreicht heute dass unsere
Solidarität kein Lippenbekenntnis ist
die Machthaber im Iran müssen wissen sie
haben keine Zukunft und wir werden Ihnen
das Leben so schwer machen wie wir es
können weitere Verantwortliche kommen
auf die Sanktionslisten wir wollen nicht
nur ihr Vermögen einfrieren sondern auch
solches das von ihnen stammt und sich
bei Dritten befindet wir werden Behörden
in die Lage versetzen sanktioniertes
Vermögen aufzuspüren wir werden Visa
sperren ausweiten und wir werden die
Sanktionen auch beim Handel verschärfen
damit geltendes Recht nicht umgangen
wird solange sie Menschenrechte mit
Füßen treten wird es keine normalen
Beziehungen geben für die demokratische
Zivilgesellschaft müssen wir tun was wir
können lassen sie uns Brücken zu
Kulturwissenschaft und NGOs
aufrechterhalten wir müssen beim Aufbau
eines freien Internets unterstützen und
wir müssen iranische Stimmen vor
regimekräften in Deutschland konsequent
schützen wir müssen humanitäre Visa
vergeben und Asylverfahren für
Iranerinnen und Iraner erleichtern denn
das ist was Solidarität konkret bedeutet
meine Damen und Herren
den Menschen im Iran sagen wir haltet
durch die Zukunft des Irans ist eine die
ihr bestimmt wir stehen an eurer Seite
meine Großmütter werden die Befreiung
dieses großartigen Landes leider nicht
erleben aber meine Mutter meine Tanten
meine Cousinen deren Töchter und
Millionen von Frauen im Iran die der
ganzen Welt gerade beweisen dass
Frauenrechte dass Menschenrechte nicht
gegeben werden sondern von Geburt an
bestehen dann sende die orsadi ich danke
Ihnen für die Aufmerksamkeit
kW am Mann sorry hat hier natürlich noch
mal seine Familie erwähnt seine Eltern
sind aus dem Iran nach Deutschland
gekommen erst dann schon in Gießen
geboren hat aber natürlich
hier auch immer noch viele Verbindungen
Norbert Röttgen spricht jetzt für die
Unionsfraktion herr Präsident sehr
geehrte Kolleginnen und Kollegen
das was wir seit einigen Wochen im Iran
erleben das ist in der Dimension und in
der gesellschaftlichen breite natürlich
nicht in den Intentionen nur mit einem
historischen Ereignis vergleichbar
nämlich dem Sturz des Schah im Jahre
1979 und der Islam mit der folgenden
islamischen Revolution
das ist keine Prognose wie es ausgeht
aber ich beschreibe das um die Dimension
des Geschehens zu verdeutlichen es geht
nicht mehr nur um Proteste sie haben es
auch gesagt der Kollege sondern es ist
eine revolutionäre Bewegung im Iran im
Gange
und daraus folgt dass für Deutschland
die Zeit gekommen ist dass wir uns
entscheiden es ist jetzt nicht mehr die
Zeit zu lavieren sondern Deutschland
muss Position und Partei beziehen in
dieser historischen Situation
schon in ihrem Titel greifen Sie diese
Dimension nicht auf sie sprechen von
Protesten aber es geht um revolutionäre
Bewegung die im Iran stattfindet die
richtige Antwort Deutschlands müsste
sein
maximalen Druck auf das Regime maximale
Unterstützung für die Protestierenden
das wäre die richtige deutsche
Außenpolitik
wir erleben
wir erleben das Gegenteil und auch in
diesem Antrag ist es wieder dokumentiert
man könnte fast glauben dieser Antrag
von den Fraktionen ist im Auswärtigen
Amt geschrieben worden weil der Antrag
auch den Geist atmet Deutschland macht
in dieser Situation
mini-sanktionen Deutschland macht nur
das was das obligatorische Mindestmaß an
Druck für das Regime ist und dadurch
fühlen sich die Protestierenden im Stich
gelassen meine Damen und Herren
Deutschland leistet zu wenig
[Applaus]
zum Bündnis 90 die Grünen ja
Brugger stellte Zwischenfrage ihre Rede
wie auch über ihre letzte Rede mehr als
irritiert und kann ihn auch nur
empfehlen mal ihren Antrag neben unseren
zu legen und was glauben Sie eigentlich
warum der deutsche Botschafter im Iran
dauernd eingestellt wird warum von
außenpolitischer Einmischung geredet
wird warum gerade unsere Außenministerin
baerbock dort zu Speerspitze des
Widerstands der Kritik und vor allem der
konkreten Maßnahmen gegen dieses Regimes
immer wieder mit aller Härte kritisiert
wird haben sie nicht mitbekommen das ist
bereits ein Sanktionspaket gab dass das
nächste ansteht dass die Listung
weiterer Person vorbereitet wird das ist
eine deutsche Initiative war ebenso die
Frage dass Menschenrechtsrat zu
thematisieren Maßnahmen zu
erkundenability auf den Weg zu bringen
zum Schutz der Zivilbevölkerung das
alles hat diese Bundesregierung
geleistet und natürlich wünschen wir uns
alle wir hätten ein Instrument diese
Gewalt zu beenden wer tut das nicht aber
hören ja hier auf zu behaupten dass
diese Bundesregierung nichts tut sondern
es ist Annalena Werbung die hier an der
sperrspitze des Widerstandes
Frau Kollege
ich glaube dass sowohl sie wie auch die
bundesaußenministerin
übereinstimmen dass keiner von uns sich
anmaßen sollte wie wir die wir hier in
Sicherheit sind stehen und debattieren
in einem freien Parlament dass wir an
der Spitze irgendeines Widerstandes
stehen an der Spitze des Widerstandes
stehen die Frauen und Männer im Iran die
für ihren Freiheitskampf gefoltert und
getötet werden also wir alle glaube ich
tun gut daran mit einem angemessenen Maß
an Demut unterscheidenheit in dieser
Watte teilzunehmen
aber ihr Punkt ist der ganz
entscheidende Punkt
dass der Botschafter sie wollen hier
darstellen dass die einbestellung des
Botschafters Ausdruck ist der
Entschiedenheit der Politik der
Sanktionspolitik und der
unterstützungspolitik Deutschlands das
ist glaube ich wenn das das Maß an
Reaktion ist dass sie herbeiführen
wollen dann ist es ein Beweis dafür dass
es einfach zu wenig ist es ist einfach
eine Realität
dass die bundesaußenministerin tagelang
nach dem Mord Angina massa-amini
geschwiegen hat es ist eine Realität
dass in Kanada 10.000 Angehörige der
revolutionsgarten sanktioniert sind dass
die USA dabei sind die
Internet-Kommunikation wieder
herzustellen und Deutschland und Europa
rühmt sich dass elf Personen
sanktioniert worden sind und vier
Organisationen Herr Bundeskanzler sie
haben sich zu diesem Thema in zwei
Tweets bislang geäußert ich bin ganz
sicher und überzeugt dass wenn Sie sich
einmal in persönlicher Rede dieser
historischen Situation stellen würden es
würden die Protestierenden Frauen im
Iran es lohnen die Iraner in Deutschland
die iranischem in den deutschen es
wirklich begrüßen wenn sie als
Regierungschef Deutschlands sich hier zu
Wort melden würden
[Applaus]
ich gehe wieder zu meiner Rede es ist
eine Politik
des minimalen Drucks auf das Regime
die bundesaußenministerin hat am 30.10
in der ARD gesagt
und ich bleibe bei ihrem Thema Frau
Kollegin Burger wo die Zeit natürlich
wieder läuft sie haben gesagt Frau
bärbock es werde geprüft und ich zitiere
jetzt wie wie wir die revolutionsgarten
auch als Terrororganisation Listen
können das war ihre Ankündigung am 30.10
vor neun Tagen bislang ist nichts
passiert und in diesem Antrag steht
nichts davon dass die revolutionsgarten
als Terrororganisation gelistet werden
soll es ist nichts von ihrer Seite
passiert ich wäre sehr dankbar sie reden
gleich wenn Sie uns das Ergebnis nach
neun Tagen ihre Ankündigung vielleicht
der Prüfung einmal mitteilen könnten
denn jetzt sind nicht Prüfungen gefragt
sondern Taten sind gefragt Handeln
Entscheidungen klare Signale alles das
ist gefragt
das Regime hat in der Zwischenzeit als
die Regierung anfing zögerlich zu
agieren ein bisschen was zu machen immer
weiter eskaliert sie haben es auch eben
beschrieben die ersten Hinrichtungen
sind erfolgt die Gewalt wird immer
brutaler Menschen werden gefoltert
14.000 Menschen sitzen in den
Gefängnissen das Parlament hat gerade
mit größter mehr mit großer Mehrheit
beschlossen und gefordert was praktisch
jeder protestierende hingerichtet wird
wenn diese Revolution scheitert dann
wird es Hinrichtungen in Massen geben
wie man sie selbst im Iran noch nicht
gekannt hat was ist dann eigentlich ihre
Politik was machen sie dann und um das
zu verhindern müssen sie doch jetzt
aktiv werden und nicht dann wenn es
passiert wieder ihr Bedauern äußern wir
müssen endlich handeln
in ihrem Antrag
gibt es auch eine Passage
der Transparenz
warum machen Sie diese Politik die wir
für grundfall schalten das beschreiben
sie doch implizit
indem sie nämlich auf Seite 4 des
Antrages schreiben und ausführen
dass das Scheitern der Verhandlungen um
das nuklearabkommen eine immense und
unberechenbare Gefahr für die gesamte
Region wäre
die größte Gefahr ist das Regime für die
gesamte Region und das mal klarzustellen
dieses Terrorregime dass die gesamte
Region in Flammen sitzt aber ich stimme
dieser Aussage zu
ich stimme der Aussage zu dass wir alles
daran setzen dass das nuklearabkommen
wirksam wird und wir haben alles daran
gesetzt aber sie machen zwei
grundlegende Fehler zwei gewaltige
Fehler der erste Fehler ist in ihrem
Festklammern an das nuklearabkommen
Verschließen sie die Augen vor der
inzwischen eingetretenen Realität sie
schreiben das Regime war ich habe jetzt
das genaue Zitat leider nicht mehr wahr
nur zögern konstruktiv zurückhaltend
konstruktiv in diesen Verhandlungen nein
die Realität ist das Regime hat den
europäischen Vorschlag das letzte Wort
das Äußerste Angebot brüsk abgelehnt hat
dieses Angebot mit
unangenehmbaren Forderungen verbunden
und spielt in dieser Frage nur noch auf
Zeit um die atomwaffenfähigkeit in
dieser Zeit zu erreichen das ist die
Realität sie klammern sich an etwas was
der Iran schon lange aufgegeben hat
letzte Bemerkung
selbst wenn es eine Chance gäbe das
atomabkommen zu retten
wäre ihre Politik falsch
denn was erleben wir im Iran nicht
irgendein Protest wir erleben dass die
Menschen Aufstehen in der Breite der
Gesellschaft für ihre Würde für ihre
Freiheit und historische Veränderung im
Iran ist möglich und in dieser Situation
haben wir nicht das Recht andere
Prioritäten zu setzen wir haben die
Pflicht das zu unterstützen meine Damen
und Herren und die Bundesregierung ich
appelliere an Sie in dieser Situation
der Möglichkeit historischer Veränderung
positionieren Sie Deutschland auf der
richtigen Seite der Geschichte auf der
Seite von Würde und Freiheit für die die
Iranerinnen und Iraner kämpfen vielen
Dank
[Applaus]
hat die bundesaußenministerin Anna-Lena
bärburg hier ja schon sehr deutlich
angesprochen und kritisiert und wir
werden sehen ob sie jetzt darauf
eingehen wird sie hält hier nämlich als
nächstes ihre Rede
liebe Kolleginnen und Kollegen sehr
geehrte Damen und Herren liebe
Schülerinnen und Schüler Gina Maser
Amini ist 22 Jahre alt als sie getötet
wird
ist 17 als er die Schule schwänzt und
man Protesten in der iranischen Stadt
marciat teilzunehmen bei seiner
Beerdigung fragt sein Vater welches
Verbrechen sein Sohn begangen haben soll
dafür dass ihm 24 Schrotkugeln in den
Bauch gejagt wurden
Nika shakarani ist 16 als sie bei
Protesten in Teheran getötet wird
Mohammad rachshani und omed sarani aus
sistan und balucistan sind 12 und 13
Kinder
ist 62
Kurdin an ihrem Grab steht ihre Tochter
ihre Haare sind abrasiert ihr Blick
dringt den Smart ihr Foto ging um die
Welt
getötet ihren Familien entrissen
Masa obdol Nika Mohammad
omed Nino
sie sind sechs von geschätzt über 300
Menschen die getötet und ihren Familien
entrissen wurden weil sie für das
eingestanden sind was für uns
selbstverständlich ist das Recht frei
über ihr Leben zu entscheiden das Recht
in Würde zu leben
dafür gehen die Frauen und Männer in
Iran seit fast zwei Monaten auf die
Straße
wer 14.000 Menschen sind dabei verhaftet
verschleppt worden
und das Regime droht Protestierenden
auch mit der Todesstrafe
angesichts der Wucht angesichts dieser
Brutalität
reichen mahnende Worte nicht aus und ich
verstehe nicht wie man sich über Tweets
an dieser Stelle austauschen kann ich
glaube dass es Aufgabe von
verantwortungsvoller Politik ist
dass wir strategisch und ehrlich die
Herren von der CDU analysieren wie wir
diesen Menschen beistehen können nicht
indem wir hier aus einem sicheren Raum
Versprechung machen
sie haben mit keinem Wort die Namen
dieser Menschen erwähnt und wissen Sie
was nein wissen Sie was ich habe mir
sehr genau überlegt ob ich auf ihre Rede
eingehe aber ihre Rede wird ja zum Glück
wir sind in einem freien Parlament
weltweit gehört deswegen möchte ich
genau auf Ihre Punkte eingehen
warum nehmen wir uns Zeit und
sanktionspakete zu verabschieden weil
wir zum Glück in einer Demokratie und in
einem Rechtsstaat leben in einer
gemeinsamen europäischen Union so leben
die die Menschen in Iran das gerne tun
würden und wissen Sie was ich möchte
nicht dass eine einzige Person entlüftet
wird auf unseren Sanktionslisten so wie
das auch passiert ist bei Listung von
russischen Akteuren wir haben strenge
Regeln dafür sie fragen mich warum ich
auf die anderen Europäer eingehe warum
ich warte warum ich nicht wie die
Kanadier vorgehe weil alles rechtssicher
sein muss sie sind Jurist sie wissen
dass sie in Teilen andere Rechtssysteme
haben als sie Amerikaner und die
Kanadier wenn ich möchte dass jede
Person verantwortlich zur Rechenschaft
gezogen wird dann reicht es nicht in den
ich hier reflexhaft irgendwelche Zahlen
in den Raum stehe sondern ich möchte
wenn ich den mutigen Frauen und Männern
im Iran verspreche ich stehe an eurer
Seite dass ich rechtssicher gemeinsam
mit den Europäerinnen und Europäern an
ihrer Seite stehe sie haben sie haben
hier gefragt jetzt hören Sie auf die
Antworten auf ihre Fragen sie haben hier
gefragt was wir seit neun Tagen mit
Blick auf die terrorlistung getan haben
ich sage Ihnen was das auszusprechen das
war gewagt weil wir eben ein anderes
Rechtsverständnis haben als die
terroristung die damals noch von Herrn
Trump passiert ist ich fand es wichtig
dass auszusprechen um deutlich zu machen
dass mein aus meinem politischen
Verständnis
dass terroristische Aktionen gegen die
eigene Bevölkerung sind sie sind Jurist
sie wissen aber wie die terroristung in
Europa ist da kann ich einfach die
deutsche Außenministerin sagen das ist
jetzt meine persönliche Auffassung
deswegen machen wir das in Europa so
sondern wir müssen uns die Rechtslage
anschauen können wir uns gerne gemeinsam
tun und da kommen viele andere Europäer
zu anderen Auffassung und wissen Sie was
es klingt jetzt vielleicht so aber das
bin ich mittlerweile gewöhnt
dass ich eine Frau rechtfertigen muss
sie sie haben sie haben gefragt sie
haben gefragt warum
Agnieszka broga gefragt hat warum der
Botschafter einbestellt wird meinen sie
ist es ein Zufall dass ich der iranische
Außenminister beim hohen beauftragten
Borell über die deutsche Außenministerin
beschwert ich möchte hier einmal ganz
und diplomatisch reden wenn wir an der
Seite der Frauen der Männer im Iran
stehen wollen dann ist unsere
Verantwortung so wie wir das auch getan
haben bei dem mutigen Menschen im
Belarus dass wir gemeinsam ganz ehrlich
sagen wo auch unsere Baustellen sind wo
unsere Maßnahmen sind weil wir eben
nicht von außen einfach so eingreifen
können es gibt Dinge die würden wir uns
gerne wünschen die sind aber in den
internationalen Beziehungen die sind in
Rechtssystemen nicht möglich und
deswegen möchte ich auch an diesem
heutigen Tag unterstreichen deswegen
möchte ich auch an diesem heutigen Tag
unter erst haben sie gesagt sie
kritisieren den Passus zum jcpoa und
dann haben sie gesagt aber irgendwie
kritisieren sie ihn doch nicht diese
Haltung kann man sich als
Bundesregierung nicht leisten und ich
möchte an diesem heutigen Tag deutlich
unterstreichen warum es für uns als
Bundesregierung so zentral ist dass
dieses Regime dass das Existenzrecht
Israels infrage stellt niemals zu einem
nuklearen Waffenarsenal kommt ich habe
mehrfach deutlich gemacht es gibt keine
Verhandlung das haben wir bei in Münster
bei G7 unterstrichen aber ich werde
niemals diesen Regime ein Blankoscheck
zu geben zu sagen jetzt akzeptieren wir
doch irgendwie dass ihr nuklear anreich
hat nein diese nukleare Anreicherung die
muss gestoppt werden mit Blick auf das
Existenzrecht Israels und auch zum
Schutz der Menschen in Iran
und ich kann ich kann niemanden
versprechen ich kann niemanden
versprechen ob das alles Wirkung zeigt
zur Realität gehört das wissen wir nicht
Politik ist kompliziert Außenpolitik
erst recht weil wir eben von außen in
dieser Situation die Menschen in Iran
beistehen ich weiß nicht ich glaube das
weiß niemand das wissen auch nie sie
nicht wie das Regime weiter vorgehen
wird was sich aber weiß ist wir lassen
nicht nach jeden Tag werden wir
versuchen weitere sanktionspakete auf
den Weg zu bringen ich telefoniere mir
gerade die fingerwunsch damit wir
Menschenrechtsrat endlich den
accountability-mechanismus aktivieren
können ob das gelingt können sie mich
dann wieder befragen ich weiß es nicht
shinyang ist im Menschenrechtsrat
gescheitert das zeigt aber wie wichtig
ist dass wir uns tagtäglich dahinter
klemmen weil alle die für Menschenrechte
arbeiten wissen wie wichtig es ist für
die Opfer dass die Täter unsere
Rechenschaft gestohlen werden und
deswegen stehen wir ich komme zum
Schluss an der starken an der Seite der
starken Frauen und Männer in Iran so
lange es notwendig ist wir tragen ihre
Stimme in die Welt sie heißen Masa sie
heißt Nika sie heißen abdulphasell sie
heißen Mohammad sie heißen Omid sie
heißen Minou mindestens 30 von ihnen
sind Kinder und sie sind stärker als das
Unrecht und die Gewalt herzlichen Dank
eine sichtlich bewegte
Außenministerin Anna-Lena baerbock ist
hier direkt auch auf die Kritik der
Union eingegangen hat auch noch mal
betont dass die Bundesregierung ein
eu-einheitliches Vorgehen in Bezug auf
den Iran anstrebt deswegen so wollen es
auch die koalitionsfraktion man etwa mit
ein
EU-weiten Sanktionen möchte man noch
einmal das Regime unter Druck setzen
Jürgen braun spricht jetzt für die
afd-fraktion Ministerin Annalena
baerbock nicht die Iraner leiden unter
dem ullerregime sondern die
bundesaußenministerin leidet im
Auswärtigen Amt und
entblättert hier ihr entsetzlichen
Zustand in Sachen Außenpolitik es ist
wirklich beschämend es ist beschämt was
hier abgeliefert haben in den letzten
Minuten so eine Rede unglaublich
hier eine Parteien die sich niemals
kritisch zum Kopftuch in Deutschland
geäußert haben inszenieren sich jetzt
als Unterstützer der Proteste im Iran
ausgerechnet jener Proteste die sich am
Kopftuchzwang entzündet haben am
Kopftuchzwang
der den Ihnen einen Regime aufgezwungen
hat das von Anfang an von den
europäischen Linken hofiert und gestützt
worden ist die links-grünen Steinmeier
Joschka Fischer Claudia Roth und Co
haben uns jahrzehntelang weiß machen
wollen die sogenannten reforma sein ja
unsere Partner und ach so viel humaner
als Typen wie ahmadine Judd Glückwunsch
Telegramme zum Jahrestag der islamischen
Revolution und würdige atomabkommen und
sogar die vote-delegationsreisen im
Kopftuch waren die Folge am Sonntag hat
das iranische scheinparlament mit fast
80 prozentiger Mehrheit also auch mit
Unterstützung der angeblichen Reformer
beschlossen dass die Teilnahme an den
Demonstrationen fortan als Krieg gegen
aller gelten soll ein Tatbestand auf den
im Iran die Todesstrafe steht die Leben
von rund 14.000 Inhaftierten
Demonstranten befinden sich in Gefahr
allein weil sie von ihrem Recht auf
Berufsfreiheit Gebrauch gemacht haben
seit dem gewaltsamen Tod der 22-jährigen
macht saarachten Amini sind den
islamistischen Schlägertrupps der
Mullahs unzählige weitere junge Frauen
und Mädchen zum Opfer gefallen und
insgesamt geht es mittlerweile um mehr
als 300 Demonstranten Männer wie Frauen
die vom Regime in zwei Monaten ermordet
worden aber anders als wohl insgeheim im
hauswärtigen Amt erhofft reisen die
Proteste keineswegs ab nein die Proteste
gehen weiter und zwar keineswegs nur in
Teheran sondern ebenso in der Provinz
auch die dortige Bevölkerung hat seit
langem genug Formular Regie
die Islamische Republik ist ein Staat in
dem schwule vor die Wahl gestellt werden
entweder wegen Unzucht hingerichtet zu
werden oder sich sterilisieren und zu
Frauen umoperieren zu lassen und das
alles im Namen des Islam denn es gibt
eine Fatwa des aja toller cumini die das
vorschreibt
das führt dazu dass der Iran nicht nur
im Verhältnis zur Bevölkerungszahl
sondern sogar ein absoluten Zahlen das
Land mit den meisten
Geschlechtsumwandlungen weltweit ist
vielleicht haben unsere
gender-gaga-fanatiker deshalb immer so
viel für die Mullahs übriger übrig
gehabt
ein solcher Staat darf hierzulande
Interessenvertretung haben ein solcher
Staat darf hier Handlanger Vereine
gründen die auch noch als gemeinnützig
anerkannt werden und deutsche
Steuergelder aus Staatsverträgen
bekommen wie im Fall der Blauen Moschee
im Rot-Grün Hamburg
jahrelang ist deutsches Zaudern
jahrelange Halbheiten haben nur der
islamischen revolutionsgrade genutzt sie
unterhält einen Schlägertrupp alwazit
der an der Niederschlagung der
Demonstration beteiligt ist aber die
revolutionskarte ist nicht nur kriminell
islamistisch sondern auch kriminell
kleptokratisch sie hat etliche Fabriken
und Raffinerien und sich unter den Nagel
gerissen die drohnenproduktion und nicht
zuletzt dass iranische Streben nach der
Atombombe erfolgen unter Aufsicht von
revolutions-
wenn sie wirklich Druck auf das Regime
in Teheran ausüben wollen dann beenden
Sie Ihre heuchlerische Farce und
benennen Sie die Vorgänger als das was
sie sind brutaler islamistischer Terror
vielen Dank Herr Kollege braun
und in nächster Rednerin ist Renate alt
aus der FDP-Fraktion sie ist die
Vorsitzende des Ausschusses für
Menschenrechte und humanitäre Hilfe
sehr geehrter Herr Präsident sehr
geehrte Damen und Herren liebe
Kolleginnen und Kollegen werden die
Homepage des Auswärtigen Amtes aufruft
der liest dort ich zitiere vor Reisen
nach Iran wird gewarnt deutsche
Staatsangehörige werden aufgefordert
Iran zu verlassen für deutsche
Staatsangehörige besteht die konkrete
Gefahr willkürlich festgenommen verhört
und zu langen Haftstrafen verurteilt zu
werden Zitat Ende wir Deutsche können
dieser Gefahr entgehen indem wir dem
Iran einfach Fernbleiben aber über 80
Millionen Iranerinnen und Iranern können
und wollen ihre Heimat nicht einfach
verlassen die Proteste die wir im Iran
aktuell sehen sind keine einfachen
Proteste das was im Iran gerade passiert
ist eine Revolution es ist eine
frauenrevolution und wir werden bestimmt
noch ganz viel über den Iran hören hier
im Deutschen Bundestag aber es ist ja
auch viel los in der Welt und anderen
krisenherren zum Beispiel in den USA und
das werden Ihnen jetzt die Kollegen von
der Tat genauer berichten